hey everybody how's it going
welcome back to cosmic wonder where we
talk about all things pertaining to the
mcu as you are aware cosmic warren is
currently
in surgery and as it turns out the title
for the next spider-man movie was
dropped
so while he's under he has asked me to
go ahead and record this quick little
video informing you about the title
and to let you guys know he will be back
to share his thoughts on this
once he recovers and for those of you
who don't know who i am i am chris host
of the cosmic culture channel and
editor for the cosmic wonder but let's
talk about what we're here for and that
is
the spider-man 3 title which
was released on instagram in a short
clip which we posted separate to this
video but the title of the movie is
spider-man
no way home now this has a lot of
different connotations and references
but i'm gonna leave that for warren to
explain to all of you guys
when he feels better and he is up and
moving again guys thank you so much for
joining be sure to subscribe to the
channel and let warren know what you
think about this awesome title reveal in
the comments down below
and we'll see you in the next one
you